[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
symbole de purification ces feux
inscrits dans le solstice d'hiver devait
brûler dans certains villages jusqu'au
nouvel an
turcat débile mental est au dragon média
solidaridad et digérer maudit laâyoune
où des dégâts d'une manière élégante pas
comme olivier jannini d'un pion
[Musique]
ce sont les gouttes d'huile que
l'insignia doral est tombé dans l'eau
qui permettent le diagnostic qui
permettent de suivre la régression du
mal si ma ligne
[Musique]
c'est début des vacances et c'est une
passion samad d'amorcer les pessimistes
[Musique]
petit papa noël type banon
aucune
[Musique]
ce que
le haut
les jouets pour
milliers